As a writer, comedian, researcher, and DJ,
I have to have music to focus.
But I have friends who need *complete silence*
to study, write, or be productive.
So which one’s better for our brain and our body?
Let’s start by finding out what noise, the
opposite of silence, does to our bodies.
Studies were conducted by the World Health
Organization that linked noise pollution,
like loud city sounds, with higher blood pressure
and a higher chance for a fatal heart attack.
All right, don’t panic, that neighbor playing
Migos at 4 a.m. isn’t going to kill you,
but prolonged exposure to a noisy environment
can lead to cognitive deficits as well.
Studies have shown that students in schools
near airports and train stations have suffered
negative effects on long-term memory and reading
comprehension, leading some cities
to require soundproofing in schools.
So, noise may not kill you,
but it increases your stress levels,
which is no bueno for your brain long-term.
Are you hearing this, construction workers
who have to fix my sidewalk at 6 a.m.?
Yeah, I'm comin' for y'all.
Silence, on the other hand, has been correlated
with lower stress hormones.
Also, studies done on mice in 2013 found that
those exposed to silence over white noise,
or even Mozart, expressed higher rates of
neurogenesis, or the production of neurons,
in the hippocampus, the part of the brain
that processes memory.
Further studies found more evidence that the
brain is processing and evaluating
new information faster in times of silence over sound.
So, less stress, new neurons, new synaptic
connections and memory formation?
Sounds good for productivity.
I know what you’re thinking: “but I do
my best work when listening to Evanescence!”
Me too. I love "Bring Me To Life."
But be patient, we’re getting there!
Music permeates all parts of the brain; not
just the temporal lobe or the auditory cortices.
If the song slaps (or if it’s trash), it’ll
activate your amygdala
and parts of your limbic system
responsible for emotional response.
What’s more, both music and language are
auditorily processed; both are forms of communication,
and I don’t know about y’all, but I consider
music like a language.
I mean, have you SEEN sheet music?
That's from a different alien race.
New research shows that there may be neurons
in the auditory cortex
that activate specifically for music;
not language, or other random sounds.
So, if your brain is busy processing emotions,
lyrics, and now there’s these new
other neurons firing, how much attention is left
to remember SOH CAH TOA?
Remember that gem from seventh grade algebra?
...I'm old.
Science says...it depends.
A 2010 study found that music may impair cognitive
abilities if you’re trying to memorize
a specific order; it could be thrown off by
a key change, a lyrical choice,
or Drake getting you deep down in your feelings.
Even if you’re not distracted, a 2006 study
measured the effects of tempo
on the cardiovascular and respiratory systems.
Slow, meditative music can get us to relax,
slowing both your heart rate and breathing
but this study found that we’re the most
relaxed when there’s a wait for it...
...pause. See what I did there?
So, silence wins?
Well, if your goal is complete zen relaxation
while you write that final,
then, yeah, try silence.
But again, this all depends on a lot of variables:
lyrics, tempo, and genre have all been shown
to have various effects on focus, mood, and
productivity.
But if you have to listen to that Randy Newman
to get those reports in, more power to you.
If you have a work or study playlist,
go for it!
Verdict: do you!
If you’ll excuse me, I have to go listen
to some Celine Dion, because I love Titanic.
♩ Near, far, where--- later, later.
Yo, what's good -- thanks for watching Seeker. Be sure to subscribe.
I'm watching you. Subscribe.
And since we talked about how silence and music affects your brain, what about ASMR?
If that really gives you the tingles, be sure to check out this episode right here
for everything scientists know about it.
If you've got two cents
and you don't know where to put it,
leave 'em in the comments below. And, as always,
thank you for watching.